parce que vous approuvez le premier
ministre quand il dit prendre ses
responsabilités forcément je suis membre
de son gouvernement
ce n'est pas la deuxième fois c'est là
c'était la deuxième occasion mais ça
avait déjà été fait et c'est pour mettre
fin à un débat qui n'a que trop duré
mais pourtant on est bien d'accord ou le
vecteur est dans l'express cette semaine
le 49-3 vous voulez le voir disparaître
oui mais vous pouvez pas mélanger une un
cadre institutionnel qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui et la nécessité de réfléchir
à moyen terme sous fasse arrêter de
penser je pense qu'il ya un sujet
démocratique dans le pays d'où le 49-3
du cas des épiphénomènes qui menait une
réflexion globale et qui devra le moment
venu être agacé envie de savoir pourquoi
vous voulez supprimer 49 3 mais c'est
quoi c'est un aveu d'impuissance non en
l'espèce si vous m'amenez à la halle
explications conjoncturelles c'est d'une
certaine manière le constat d'échec
malgré un certain nombre de propositions
de compromis d'avancé y compris par
rapport à la première lecture
l'assemblée nationale est enfermé dans
des postures qui traduisent l'état d'une
cinéma démocratique aujourd'hui qu'il
faut sortir de cela ça a quand même
beaucoup trop duré d'accord mais pas ce
que vous dites qu'il faut supprimer le
49-3 si je ne me trompe pas parce que ça
oblige à trouver un compromis donc c'est
bien un échec ça vient aujourd'hui la
cité de trouver un compromis sur cette
fameuse loi travail de 49,3 est toujours
un constat d'échec
le premier ministre l'a dit lui-même à
la tribune de l'assemblée et d'un puits
s'il est l'état puissance politique n'a
pas la puissance puisque justement celle
inverse c'est justement l'occasion de
trancher un débat qui n'a que trop duré
cc c'est l'échec de discussions d'avancé
que le gouvernement a fait qu'ils n'ont
pas permis d'aboutir à quoi vous assurez
également j'imagine que le gouvernement
a fait suffisamment d'efforts vers le
compromis je le crois je crois que je
crois que ce texte est devenu a une
portée désormais dans le débat politique
symbolique quand on regarde sa réalité
notamment ce qui pousse prem son article
2 il n'est pas vrai
d'écrire cet article comme une menace
contre les droits des travailleurs je
pense même qu'il ya des garanties
notamment sur ce qu'on appelle l'accord
majoritaire
c'est à dire le fait que pour qu'un
accord soit signé désormais il faudra au
moins 50% des salariés contre 30%
aujourd'hui quand même qu'il ya des
garanties apportées par ses copains ici
c'est devenu symbolique c'est vrai mais
je vais quand même on entend les
arguments même si on n'est pas d'accord
vous entendez benoît hamon qui dit
maintenant l'article 2 c'est synonyme de
dumping social c'est ce que disent aussi
une grande partie des syndicats
contestataires bien sûr je mets de côté
là c'est vrai les opinions sont divisés
et derrière cette division il ya
finalement la culture politique de
l'affrontement entre ceux qui
considèrent que désaccord entre des
parties sur le terrain permettent du
progrès social en tout cas mon peuvent
permanent progrès social et ceux qui
pensent que la garantie c'est d'abord la
loi c'est d'abord le vote dans
l'économie d'aujourd'hui
objectivement avec la diversité des
entreprises je pense qu'il faut la
fluidité que permettent les accords
d'entreprise alors si on se projette à
est ce que vous estimez que
supprimer le 49 3 et est fondée est ce
que vous ne craignez pas de désarmer les
gouvernements futurs mais si vous voulez
m'inviter à une réflexion globale
oui mais on peut sur une risée la
refondation démocratique soit réflexion
absolument passionnante
il ya en effet un certain nombre de
sujets qui méritent d'être reposée à
commencer par la façon dont on fabrique
la loi les pouvoirs respectifs du
parlement et de l'exécutif et la façon
de préparer les textes avant que de les
voter les concertation obligatoire les
garanties l'autorité indépendante et
donc d'entamer le débat sans réussite de
votre réflexion de bien sûr si vous êtes
ministre du gouvernement et hop vous
arriver le jour pour le premier ministre
utilise le 49 x vous dites il faudra le
supprimer un jour bien sûr mais je vous
dis sup en train de lire autre chose je
vous dis que dans une architecture de
fabrique de la loi repenser j'ai
d'ailleurs fait un rapport préparé un
rapport parlementaire que j'ai pas pu
terminer puisque j'étais nommé
gouvernement compte terminer de manière
remarquable
régis juanico dé laure de la raudière et
que dans une fabrique différente de la
loire repenser à l'image de ce qui se
fait dans les pays internationaux et
depuis on doit pouvoir se passer donc le
dispositif entre mille a changé les
choses dans le pays arrive et une
culture de compromis on
on en est loin c'est pour le reste c'est
pas du fantasme c'est des choses qui se
font des gens qui ont été mises en
oeuvre depuis dix ans oui dans un
certain nombre de pays étrangers en
europe
je pense que la france a une session de
rattrapage à faire sur des outils de
bonne gouvernance à côté desquels on est
passé depuis dix ans vous pensez que
depuis 4 2 puis 10 on réfléchit l'on
jette et on se projette y avez-vous
pensé que manuel valls pourrait être un
premier ministre sans 49,65 sans
possibilité de recours en france et il
pourrait je pense que l'on la cus et
d'affaires l'accusent d'avoir voulu
d'abord montrer ses muscles
non mais ça s'arrête là ça c'est de la
polémique politico face à existe dans la
dans la vie politique
enfin moi je me rappelle d'une chose
c'est le premier discours d'investiture
de manuel valls déclaration de politique
générale à l'assemblée nationale où il a
posé 10
règlement la question démocratique et
j'ai une conviction profonde c'est qu'il
n'est pas satisfait de la situation
d'aujourd'hui de l'état du débat
démocratique dans le bus dans le pays
2-2 finalement du fait qu' on n'est plus
dans des affrontements dans des postures
dans des petites choses que dans des
grands débats de ne pas satisfaire
je suis convaincu qu'il n'est pas
satisfait de rennes manque pas une
occasion de lire d'appeler jean la
responsabilité accord la quiétude
correct à l'assemblée france a pas trop
vous le vous l'arbitré la semaine
prochaine ou dans quinze jours il vous
répondra mais en tout cas cette question
démocratique
l'insatisfaction que produit aujourd'hui
l'état du demo de débat démocratique
d'un pays et la nécessité de leur pensée
ça je suis persuadé que lui comme le
président de la république sont
convaincus de sa valeur aujourd'hui la
faute incombe à manuel valls si on
écoute bien sûr les frondeurs mais je
vous propose d'écouter laurent baumel
qui est très dur envers le premier
ministre le diviseur manuel valls
considère qu'il a le monopole de
l'intérêt de la france du mot
responsabilité en réalité se comporte
comme quelqu'un dans cette affaire qui
avait la possibilité est de réunifier un
minimum sa famille politique de d'avoir
une sortie par le haut avec nous mais
aussi avec peut-être les syndicats et
qui cultive au nom du fait qu'il cultive
sa propre image d'autorité
d'intransigeance sa propre construction
politique finalement et médiatique est
en train de bavarder de bousiller les
possibilités de sortir de cette affaire
de la loi travail parle ou alors il ya
du vrai dans ce que dit laurent baumel
d'abord c'est pas bien de s'en prendre à
la personne du premier ministre comme il
le fait geron peut-on style sa méthode
oui non à la personne faisait une
critique politique mais personnel du
style de la méthode de la façon d'être
présumés de laurent baumel c'est pas
bien ce surtout que je crois que laurent
baumel comme d'autres et c'est tout à
fait
respectables sont des frondeurs du
premier jour moi j'ai connu laurent
baumel à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
siégé avec lui avant même que manuel
valls se soit premier ministre il était
frondeur
c'est tout à fait son droit il a droit
d'être en désaccord avec l'orientation
politique du gouvernement mais c'est pas
la personnalité de manuel valls qui est
en cause c'est une certaine lecture un
certain nombre de convictions que
laurent baumel à avec quelques-uns de
ses amis de désaccords sur la politique
du gouvernement
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut se placer
ça sert à rien essayer d'enfoncer la
personne du ministre la socialiste
karine berger estime que le premier
ministre devrait démissionner faute de
majorité
ben pourquoi démissionner faute de
majorité il va le texte va probablement
être adoptée il ya des règles
institutionnelles
là aussi on peut en penser ce qu'on veut
mais tant qu'elle existe en l'état on
les respecte parce que s'il n'y a pas de
république
la règle c'est adopter en entre 49
agents à vélo sur mon sens il y eut
enfin que motion de censure s'il ya une
motion de censure votée par l'assemblée
ça veut dire en effet qu a pas de
majorité il ya plus de majorité et qui a
pas de majorité alternative et si
y'avait pas voter soit bien qu'ils aient
une majorité donc est ce que vous avez
fait quand vous en parler certains de
vos amis du parti socialiste se dire
prêts à voter une motion de censure que
capelle d'ailleurs le parti communiste
franchement je pas envie de passer d'une
peu d'énergie que ce qu'on passe déjà
qui est démesuré à régler des histoires
entre les labels et les forces qui
composent de la majorité
vous avez été un précurseur cette
affaire de primaire est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de la manière dont ça s'engage
est ce que vous pensez comme semblent le
dire madame lienemann que ce sont
peut-être des primaires sur mesure pour
françois hollande
non je suis satisfait qu'elle ait lieu
voilà qu'elle était décidée après c'est
pas sûr que les françaises et les
français vont passer des nuits entières
à s'interroger sur le détail de la
primaire sont intéressants mais voilà
elle devait avoir lieu c'est pareil dans
une réflexion seront moins de succès que
les primaires de jeunes ans et je n'en
sais strictement rien je pense en
revanche que il ya une querelle de
famille à gauche depuis le début du
quinquennat
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière c'est
traditionnel à gauche et quand il ya une
querelle de famille c'est bien de
convoquer le conseil de famille pour la
règle et wallace est finalement c'est
sale et les primaires et c'est une bonne
chose que ça se règle comme ce serait ce
que ça peut être des primaires loyal
c'est le terme cabale le sont forcément
utilisé par arnaud montebourg avait dit
voilà que pour que ça soit loyal il faut
dix mille bureaux de vote un système de
parrainage qui efface un filtre assez
clair voilà donc il veut les conditions
de la primaire de 2011 est ce que vous
le rejoignez dans cette demande écoute
moi je suis pas ni greffier militaire
donc je vais pas compter le nombre de
bureaux de vote et mais il faut qu'elle
soit loyale mais comment peut-on
imaginer une seconde que ceux qui
décident de cette primaire décide en
même temps de la truck et voix c'est
absurde s'était vu tout ça se passe
publiquement il ya des des médias il ya
des millions de deux hommes et femmes de
gauche qui attendent ces primaires là il
n'y a pas de risque il ya aucun risque
il ya simplement un principe que tout le
monde doit accepter en participant à la
primaire c'est que le gagnant gagne et
non le gagnant a gagné ça c'est très
important parce que sinon ça veut dire
qu'on a plus rien à faire ensemble
donc il faut accepter sans aucune
réserve s'il a des exigences sur le
nombre de buts 2 2 de bureaux de vote
très bien il faut accepter cette règle
tout bête que le candidat désigné par la
primaire est le candidat de tous ceux
qui ont participé
c'est le seul cadre politique et ça
c'est évidemment
c'est à chacun de faire cet effort la
primaire semble un aveu de faiblesse
pour françois hollande donc ouais
évidemment tout le monde soupçonne mais
pourquoi manoeuvre en fait voilà qui
serait pas totalement honnête donc on
peut comprendre que les gens aient des
doutes sinon c'est pas la wii
non mais la loyauté c'est très
intéressant ce débat de la primaire
parce que derrière il ya une certaine
conception de la présidence de la
république on dit en gros ou ceux qui
s'opposent à la primaire 10 mais écoutez
le pression de la république comment
mais allez voir le peuple à aller voir
les citoyens à aller voir ceux et celles
de sa famille politique pour leur
demander s'il peut se représenter
voilà on raisonne comme si le prise en
main publique françois hollande
aujourd'hui hier d'autres de man août
étaient des sortes d'hommes
providentiels qui avait par eux mêmes
une légitimité qui faisait que
naturellement devait se représenter
moi je pense que c'est pas la bonne
vision de ce qu'est le président de la
république dans la société d'aujourd'hui
et je pense d'ailleurs que françois
hollande à cette vision la selle à
présent appuyé que c'est un premier de
cordée
c'est quelqu'un qui emmène une corde et
ceux et celles qui partagent ces
convictions pas ça peut pas être
monolithiques par free par des
désaccords qui les emmènent qui les
dirige pendant cinq ans sur un parcours
qui prend la responsabilité de
l'équipage qui indique la voie qui
parfois motive les gens qui parfois les
engueuler quand il faut les anglais et
c'est cette vision là de ce qu'est un
président de la république de ce que
doit être un président de la république
aux indiens qui je crois est annoncée
dans dans ce quinquennat elle implique
justement cette légitimation par sa
famille parce que pour être premier de
cordée vous faut une corde et voilà et
qui a d'autres dans la cordée que ceux
et celles qui participeront vote
désignant un autre candidat du coup ben
moi quand il a quand il est candidat
vous savez vous s'il va se présenter
présent la plupart des déclarations très
simple il a dit moi je serai candidat si
j'arrive à faire baisser le chômage dans
fin d'année donc on attend la fin
d'année à là où je suis dans le
gouvernement
modestement j'ai c'est pour ma part de
contribuer à cet objectif les démunis
qui sont bien plus exposé que moi au
travail à l'économie aux finances et
puis on espère que ça chômage baissera
que prison pour être candidat mais pour
l'instant nul n'en sait rien
nous avons tous moi même une
responsabilité de remettre de la qualité
et du respect dans le débat démocratique
parce que si on tire pas le débat vers
le haut y'a pas de raison que les
comportements absolument inadmissible ne
prospérait ce que la qualité du débat ne
concerne pas d'abord les ministres entre
eux on a assisté hier à une scène
étrange sur twitter avec ce qu'on dit on
appelle un tweetclash vous avez vu un
avec des bisbilles avec christian eckert
soutenu d'ailleurs par manuel valls et
le rançonnement où va-t-on avec vous le
voyez emmanuel macron épinglé par le
secrétaire d'état au budget et manuela
concaret qualifié de 2,2 sur rome voilà
ça c'est twitter
ailleurs c'est rien mais quand ils te
pas twitter ce sont les ministres à vous
demander narbonnais d'appeler à
l'apaisement des urbains non mais c'est
un média qui a une audience par leur dit
aux médias non parce que j'avais peur
mais je ne dis pas que le média est
responsable ce que je veux dire c'est
que twitter ça fait partie de ces
nouveaux outils numériques qui sont
finalement des outils à épanchements de
ses propres états d'âme voilà et là il a
été vexé et peut-être pour des bonnes
raisons puisqu'il est responsable des
douanes
donc il a écrit naturellement ce qu'il
ce qu'ils sentaient voilà et on peut
comprendre la réaction d'humeur de
christian eckert
comme j'ai une petite question vous
étiez
vous avez soutenu arnaud montebourg en
2011 et pour la primaire du ps à cette
époque qu'est ce que vous pensez de ses
premiers pas en fin de son retour en
politique il ya une grosse incertitude
politique avec arnaud montebourg j'ai du
mal à pour l'instant mais probablement
le clarifier ratés de ses positions dans
les semaines qui viennent
comprendre sa position sur une question
qui pour moi est majeur qui la question
européenne
je me demande s'il n'est pas en train de
devenir souverainiste or je pense pour
ma part que l'europe a besoin d'être
paramétrer mais a vraiment besoin non
seulement d'exister reconsolider par une
façon un peu différente de la faire
fonctionner que ce qui a fonctionné
aujourd'hui dit c'est qu'il faut mener
un bras de fer avec l'europe pour la
reconstruire et enfin voilà aider à sa
reconstruction
est-ce que c'est pas justement ce que
fait par exemple magna mais valls quand
il dit que de manière unilatérale il
pourrait ne pas appliquer la directive
sur les travailleurs détachés il n'y a
pas la france et l'europe il n'y a pas
la france d'un côté l'europe de l'autre
la france surtout avec leur évite c'est
la deuxième économie européenne c'est au
coeur de l'europe voulait faire un bras
de fer avec qui avec vous même donc si
la france ne porte pas des projets de
construction renforcée de nouveaux
horizons pour des coopérations entre les
pays
si plutôt que de faire un compte un bras
de fer avec on sait pas trop qui elles
portent pas une dimension constructive
la france il ya dans leur vie j'ai alors
l'europe mais évidemment le constat
qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie que les
procédures politiques sont trop longues
à faire tout ça ça a été fait et refait
on n'en est plus là c'est sert à rien de
le problème c'est comment on fait pour
que cette belle idée quelle idée
européenne
cannes a quand même pris un grand coup
dans l'oeil comment on fait pour qu'elle
renaisse qu'elle à la fois que qu'elle
redevienne ce qu'elle a été un espoir
pour des millions de de français et
d'européens et moi je pense que
l'énergie d'un responsable politique
aujourd'hui c'est pas de passer son
temps à taper sur cette europe dont les
dons les absences et insuffisantes sont
visibles mais plutôt de redéfinir en
quoi on faire remarcher
cette machine qui est en panne parce que
faire de la sélection à la fac est ce
que c'est un gros mot puisque c'est un
tabou a coûté moi je pense que la vraie
formulation sémantique c'est d'être
exigeants sur l'orientation renforcée
des étudiants après enfin des futurs
étudiants
après le bac je pense que je vais
boutique
je vais être très clair vous avez des
bacs qui ont c'est très précisément ne
prépare pas forcément à la réussite en
première année de licence vous avez d un
certain type de bac rentrons pas dans le
détail c'est pas très important où vous
où statistiquement vous êtes 3% de
chances de réussite à la naissance donc
ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait le tri on leur
dit pas non pourquoi il ya 3 % ces trois
là ça aurait été dommage de les
interdire
on explique et c'est tous les projets
d'orientation qui s'amorce là qu'on a
recommencé qu'on a commencé pour la
première année cette année qu'on va
renforcer les prochains on explique on
doit avoir au lycée au moment où un pli
apb quelqu'un qui vous dit c'est ce que
j'appelle l'orientation renforcée
franchement tu devrais pas fait recette
c'est tu devrais pas l'air mathématiques
alors que donc on appelle ce à quoi deux
sélections je nomme de l'orientation
sélection vous dit pas non par principe
parce que vous c'est bien ou c'est pas
bien vous sait pas quand ça se déclenche
un enfant vous savez pas quand ça se
déclenche un étudiant il ya bien des cas
très variées vous avez des gens qui d'un
seul coup en premier ne deviennent les
très bons élèves
et puis d'autres c'est en deuxième année
glissant dont vous savez pas mais vous
devez en revanche faire beaucoup plus
d'efforts pour orienter dans des
filières où ils ont des chances de
réussite des élèves qui ont fauté sipho
clair pour tout le monde le dit pas tout
simplement est bien c'est que j'ai en
train de faire
je m'adresse à thierry mandon évidemment
pour je suis confiant qu'il maintiendra
cette vigilance par rapport au budget de
la recherche c'est surtout ce que nous
avons déjà discuté que nous ayons un
budget de la recherche 2017 qui soit
assez offensif c'est ça qui est très
important pour nous alors je confirme à
monsieur jouzel à nos prix nobel un que
les crédits qui avait été un moment
convoité par des budgétaire qui cherche
toujours des sous c'est c'est comme ça
ont bien été finalement conservée
intégralement et deuxièmement je
confirme monsieur je vous l ai
accessoirement avoue même que il y aura
un effort budgétaire pour la recharge au
budget 2010 est c'est à dire ah c'est à
dire vous allez savoir dans les jours
qui viennent puisque les arbitrages sont
un effet il y aura un effort budgétaire
pour la recherche le président de la
république s'y est engagé il y aura un
effort budgétaire sur la recherche de
manière générale sur les organismes
parce qu'ils ont des charges nouvelles
qu'il faut en partie en tout cas
financer et sur le budget de l'agencé
nationale de la recherche le montant
voté
ben c'est ce que jean louis b for budget
augmenter bah ça vous avez configuré
dans les prochains dans les prochains
jours j'ai pas envie d'avoir un tweet de
monsieur eckert aaa si je vais plus loin
que les arbitrages qui ne sont pas
encore tout à fait rendu